congressman I was about to introduce you
and say a little more hi how you doing
thank you so much for joining us tonight
we're so lucky to have you here with us
and I've already explained that you're
actually in Washington because you're
working and I was about to tell folks
that you represent the 23rd district of
Texas but maybe you could tell us a
little bit about your district and
describe it for us you're my doctorate
in southwest Texas it's 29 counties to
timezones 820 miles of border from Eagle
Pass health hurts all the way to El Paso
it takes ten and a half hours to drive
across my district at 80 miles an hour
which is the speed limit and most of the
district and I found out a couple
weekends ago it's not the speed limit in
all the districts I'm in saying no it's
a 71% Latino district and the district
that I've been representing for now my
third term in Congress and when you
think about the issue of the border I
have more border than any other member
of Congress my spent nine and a half
years as an undercover officer in the
CIA chasing a bad people all across the
country so when it comes to securing our
border it's something I know a little
bit about one of the things I learned
recently which I hadn't known before is
that your district is actually the size
I think of the state of Georgia that's
right if it's larger than six States
roughly the size of the state of Georgia
so it's pretty big so as an expert in
national security and as a member of
Congress you've been called upon to
think about issues related to
immigration and in recent years
particularly about the border wall what
is your reaction to president Trump's
statement that we need a big beautiful
wall that would stretch across our
border and at 18 to 30 feet high I've
been banging my first ran for
back in 2009 this is not a new topic
that building a 30-foot high concrete
structure and see the shining scene is
the most expensive and least effective
way to do border security there are
parts of Boulder where Border Patrol's
response time to a threat is measured in
hours to days if your response time is
measured in hours to days then a wall is
not a physical barrier and we should be
having technology along the border we
should know what's called we should have
operational control of our border which
means you know everything is going back
and forth across it can do a lot of that
with technology we also need more folks
within our Border Patrol but but in
addition to doing all this one of the
things we should be able to do is
streamline legal immigration if you're
going to be a productive member of our
society
let's get you here as quickly as
possible but let's do it legally and if
we able to streamline that then you're
gonna see some of the pressures really
need along our border and Lao men and
women Border Patrol to focus on human
trafficking and drug trafficking
organizations as well congressman
there's also been a conversation
nationally about using emergency funds
to build the border wall and taking
those funds from the United States
military what is your position been on
that issue you know I'm one of the few
Republicans up here that has opposed
that that effort we are just now
rebuilding our military and taking funds
away from making sure that our our
brothers and sisters our wives and our
husbands have the training and equipment
they need in order to take care of us
and in in far-flung places I'm taking
money away from them is not an efficient
use of our resources especially if it's
going to build a you know I always say
it's a fourth century a solution to a
first-century problem and the the
reality is what we should be focusing on
is some of the other root causes of this
problem and many of your speakers today
have talked about that and some of those
key would probably include problems are
violence
lack of economic opportunity and extreme
poverty specifically in northern
triangle El Salvador Guatemala and
Honduras
what would you should be worth I was
gonna ask waiter what you would
recommend the United States government
does to address the underlying what we
call push factors or root causes in
those three countries in Central America
well one of the things I learned as an
undercover officer in the CIA is be nice
with nice guys and tough with tough guys
and one of the principles of being nice
with night guys is is shrinking our
alliances um we have a number of
programs currently in these three
countries that USAID and State
Department is doing to address this
violence issue we know in El Salvador
one of the problems was that the police
were corrupt and so we've worked with
the Salvadorans to purge the police we
hire new folks news community policing
tactics these are tactics that the men
and women in American and police forces
I use every single day and when we did
this and strength communities guess what
happened we saw an increase in the
violence that was happening in those
communities and then we also saw a
decrease in the number of people that
were leaving those areas to try to come
to the United States illegally so it's a
fraction of the car the solve a problem
there before it ultimately reaches our
border and and one of the reasons that
you have violence and crime is political
corruption and the lack of funchal
governments to protect its citizens and
so this is something we should be
continuing to work on
we shouldn't be decreasing the amount of
money that we have that we're sending
from these countries I actually think we
should be increasing it I believe the
first thing and we should have done this
months ago is select a special
representative a little northern
triangle that's a senior diplomat that's
gonna work to make sure that we're using
all of our levers of power to help these
three countries and then that we're
dealing in a coordinated effort we
should also with the - upon the United
States Mexico this is a problem for the
entire West
there so where is the Organization of
American States where is the
International Development Bay and we
should be having a collective plan to
address this these root causes and when
you talk about violence a lot of times
we talk about these terrible games like
ms-13
but it's also violence like women being
beaten by their husbands and they have
nobody else to go to and they are unable
to deal with this current problem so
these are the types of injuries that we
should be increasing our diplomacy
increasing or economic eliminated please
I want to take you now from thinking
about the root causes in Central America
to thinking about the separation of
children and families in the United
States starting in April 2018 the Trump
administration began a no tolerance
policy for immigrants people seeking
refugee status asylum in the United
States and that led to the separation of
2,700 children in the first year that
that program was run now I want to
address this with you and I want to
separate it upfront into two different
conversations one of the things that the
administration did was file legal court
papers saying that one of the primary
purposes of the separations was to act
as a deterrent against people coming to
the United States and I want to talk for
a moment about that from a moral
perspective and to get your views we
shouldn't be doing it is it's real
simple and guess what it wasn't a
deterrent you only saw an increase in
the amount of illegal immigration and
when you're sitting in the good you know
debating a strategy your strategy if
somebody comes up with the idea of
snatching a child out of their mother's
arms you need to go back to the drawing
board
this is not what what the United States
of America stands for this is not a
Republican or Democrat or independent
thing this is a human decency thing and
so still using that strategy it didn't
achieve the ultimate purpose and
ultimately that the
the amount of research done and the
impact that the detention of children
has especially if it's over 21 days as
on their development and in their future
is disaster so we shouldn't be trying to
detain me my children for any more than
21 days and we should be getting
children if they're in our custody which
he taking care of and mainly and making
sure they're with people that can
provide them a safe and and loving in
part I would challenge you even on the
21-day number but for the purposes of
this conversation I want to follow up on
something you just said which is that
both that it's wrong to detain children
and that it's not effective so the
question then is why does the
administration continue to do it when
we've seen 900 additional children
separated from their parents since the
summer of 2018 why is this happening
well that's something that you'd have to
ultimately ask the administration see
these are questions that I've been
asking the Tornillo facility is in my
district these are leaders are buildings
that are not designed to hold anybody
for for multiple days let alone children
we should be making sure that if they
are in our custody a lot of times for
the unaccompanied children we don't have
a we don't know of a patron or a family
member the United States and we should
make sure that they're in facilities
where they're able to go to school and
have proper food and healthcare and if
we're able to find a sponsor or a family
member
let's get them into that those custody
while they're waiting for their
immigrant immigration court case that's
the other issue here when you have a
backlog of cases I think it's now
900,000 cases that are backlog we should
be able to do an immigration hearing
within nine months I think most of the
legal community thinks that is enough
time to do something like this so that
we can facilitate whether someone or an
individual is able to stay in the United
States or whether they have to be
returned back to their own country
rather than being in this limbo for five
years if we think about the
caelum system today where people are
coming and saying that they have a
credible threat that they will be
persecuted back home and we think about
the fact that on average it's about two
years for someone to get an asylum
hearing that many people are not
represented as they go through that
process it makes me think about
something that they say in the
healthcare space all the time
which is that every system is perfectly
designed to get the results it gets and
so as you think about this and think
about how we would redesign this system
to not do what we're doing which is
years and years of detention and
separations and hardship for people
seeking and again in Asylum being a
lawful United States government process
for people seeking to enter our country
lawfully what should we do I've tried it
increased by four billion dollars the
amount of resources that HHS has in
order to specifically deal ultimately
with children I think we need more
immigration judges in order to process
these cases and I think we need to
ensure that folks that can get
representation I've been able to work
with a number of lawyers up and down the
border make sure that they're being able
to get access to the folks that are
having these problems and so this is
this is something that we should be able
to sign and only when it comes to
children we should be doing everything
we can custody in order to in order to
take care of them so I have two more
questions for you before I'm gonna let
you go back to work the first is about
our focus in the United States on the
questions of immigration because if you
look at some of the statistics you see
that of people who are undocumented in
the United States the majority of people
have overstayed on visas they haven't
come through the border if you look at
the people who try to enter the country
who are on the terrorist watch list they
enter overwhelmingly through the
airports and not through the border if
we look at drugs coming into the United
States which has been a huge part of
this conversation the vast majority of
those drugs come through our
quartz and through other points of entry
not through backpacks on people crossing
the border so the thing I always ask and
I always worry about with government is
that we focus so much on one thing and
my question for you is whether we are
focused on this conversation nationally
about the border every day and every
minute of every day whether it's we're
looking completely in the wrong
direction
I would agree your premise when you have
let's start with the economic benefits
when you have a three point six percent
unemployment what does that mean
that means you need folks in every
industry whether it's agriculture or
artificial intelligence so why aren't we
streamlining legal immigration
we should be able to make this
market-based in order to have folks come
in and be productive members of our
society when it comes to when it comes
to the drug issue you talking about yes
it's in our ports of entry but it's also
coming into our shores a Coast Guard is
only able to action 25 percent of the
known intelligence they have on drugs
coming in into our country the the
metric that we should be measuring if
are we seeing a decrease of death on
from overdose from drugs overseas are we
seeing and a decrease in illegal
immigration it's not how many miles of
fencing that we that we that we have
ultimately built and so we have
benefited from the brain drain of every
other country the last couple decades I
want to see that continue and I want to
see that continuing with a hard-working
drain and I can tell you this last
Congress Pete Aguilar is a Democrat from
California and I had a piece of
legislation called the USA act strong
border security streamline legal and
immigration fixed doctah 1.2 million
kids who have only known the United
States of America as their home these
kids are actually say young men women
there are any Americans let's let's not
have them go through any more
uncertainty and make that ultimately
happen we had 245 people that were
willing to sign this bill in the law it
wasn't allowed to come forward under a
Republican speaker and also the current
Democratic speaker hasn't brought this
bill doing something that we have
able to pass so I want to close and you
are perhaps most famous I don't know if
that's fair but you took a road trip
with beta O'Rourke from your district to
Washington DC and you become known for
reaching across the aisle and engaging
in these bipartisan conversations and
one of the things I've seen you say
repeatedly is to talk about how we are
all united and I think when we think
about the language of immigration and we
start hearing words about enemies and
militarization I think the real question
is how do we how do we convince all
Americans to understand what you say
that more unites us than divides us
criss-crossing and dishes like mine
that's 250 percent Democratic Republican
it's very clear to me that way more you
know I definitely focus on the things
that we agree will be all better off and
now I'm not gonna get a perfect
attendance award for going to church but
I do remember when when Jesus was in the
second simple and the Pharisees asked
him what's the most important
commandment he said to love thy Lord God
with all your heart mind soul but people
forget he also said equally as important
is to love thy neighbor like myself and
if we remember that and realize what it
would mean and what you would have to be
going through to be living in a
situation that you made send your child
on a 3,000 mile parallel Chikku because
the optic only and for their future is
only think that that you can do to make
sure their future is bright if we all
remember that situation I'm big well we
will do situation I think we don't need
that Thank You congressman thank you so
much for joining us tonight